hello reject nation its Greg Alda here
and it's John Humphrey over here we saw
cars brass what colors are marys mine
that's right yeah that's how she talks
she's like super like stereotypical
Spanish yeah tire remotely regrets him
way back
okay so cars one I thought was kind of a
snoozefest to be honest I know you
thought it was okay yeah like cars - I
keep intending for like the past few
years to watch it it's never really
found the energy to like put it on a
television yeah
samesies the trigger to make me want to
see it nobody else maybe not see it so I
didn't see cars three I would say that
it's not a bad movie I was I was
pleasantly surprised basic breakdown oh
I want I really want to keep this review
short the findings old after like the
first 30 minutes of this movie I was
starting to get questionable I was
zoning out a little bit I was like oh
man this might be a little it sound like
a knowing or something it just I'm just
not invested in it with this plot of the
movie Lightning McQueen yeah the whole
movie everyone your money and he's old
he's it something like all there annular
cars they got a crazy rocky for bit like
Aki for you dudes to training and labs
and [ __ ] like you're outdoors say and
know what cars are much more
technologically advanced lightning
McQueen is losing races he ends up
having that moment in the crazy teaser
trailer where his card you know to get
totally damaged spins out of control
yeah now he's recruited after like four
or five months skip all the recuperation
yeah we don't get right out it was like
why beat around the bush let's just go
right to him and going out or I don't
need to get back in the field and I need
to learn how to be faster smarter or
whatever the main dynamics I mean
plotted as kicks in when he has a new
trainer clues Ramirez you see that the
enemy of the film
Ivan Drago is a Jackson storm Armie
Hammer Armie Hammer who's a whole roll
is the days it's only a dick dick come
all he does I'll Jack the stormy at dig
and that's fine for the movie you know
really spent much time with Jackson
stormy like in it in the beginning and
at the end he checks in every ten minute
NBD a dick again just these two items
yeah it's not even like ten minutes it's
like every morning five every third one
until you barely ever spend any time
there's literally one really just cut to
him so you can say three lines that's up
yeah and when they cut back with this
movie even the story really starts to
kick in is because Cruz Ramirez is his
new trainer and she's this person who
only trained she's never raced and she
doesn't work with the awesome up-to-date
technological simulations and whatnot
but she's not a real racer and Cruz
Ramirez is assigned to Train Lightning
McQueen
but dynamics starts switching a lot
where Lightning McQueen is at times kind
of her trainer yeah man she doesn't know
anything about racing on the real yeah
she doesn't she doesn't it's like when
Ivan Drago is trying his long movies
rocking boys not injure I go is training
we on a treadmill but Rocky's run tires
no bullet lots of middle so except now
he's teaching the trainer about how to
train in the real world yeah yeah and
now they're teaching each other when the
movie gets to that point when it kicks
into Act two is when I thought the movie
started actually gathering my interest
not thinking so much Nigel II parted
watching the movie I kind of check out
when I watch cars that I do it there's
something about the world that's kind of
is weirdly confusing to me yeah I don't
you have this this world exists in the
suspension of disbelief because like
half the stuff you're like how did they
get any of them yeah any of this makes
sense
yeah and I still find lightning McQueen
that interesting of a character which is
kind of surprising to me be like oh what
if and it's such a lovable guy and then
for him to be doing this voice and he's
not that intriguing of all other Pixar
characters it's kind of shocking to me
but here I actually enjoyed him in it I
like the story art of this I know they
got a different director for this and I
felt like the story arc of it was really
cool for this racecar driver who's you
know has to accept the fact that he has
to change he has to adapt and they had a
trainer from someone who's up-to-date
with the technological advances but
she's not used to the old-school method
so you're seeing the contrast
blending in with each other we're
learning from each other at the same
time they butt heads and all that fun
stuff yeah is happening and this movie
has a really good heart I thought I feel
like the best way to tell you why this
movie's effective it's like giving away
the ending which we're not going to do
but the finale has this really nice turn
that was surprising to me
yeah arching and the movie subtly leads
up to it in a way room like that makes
sense that movie was hinting that it
would go down this direction and it's a
rewarding payoff I felt good about the
movie by the time it was over at up a
web that was very effective I started
off this movie being like okay it's kind
of like what I expected them then in the
middle of the movie I was yeah kind of
pulled into it then yeah by the end it
managed to take me by surprise I don't
think it's amazing necessarily but I
enjoyed my time there like a class that
I saw it and I feel like they brought in
some nuances that you know now on our
third Cars movie which feels to me just
like one of I guess Pixar's more broad
reaching because you said that before is
like lightning McQueen's not overly
complex you know and we've seen more
complex characters from them so yeah
once they got into the whole like you're
aging and and how do you respond to that
I thought they brought in some actually
interesting ideas to play with and at
least developed the characters that way
and the same sealer of it is cristela
Alonzo Cruz Ramirez she's a really good
character character yeah what's
interesting about her character is she
is one of those Pixar characters kind of
like dory
kind of like joy and inside out where
these are characters who can easily be
annoying but they're not and she look
not always to annoy you you're supposed
to get annoyed at lightning McGee at
annoyed you know but what the movie does
well is when they reveals other layers
to her that makes her a lot more
likeable she actually had a moment that
made John and I tear up a little bit
yeah here's less my eyeballs yeah three
of them hey you find yourself really
rooting for this character that the
movie is not really promoting her in the
trailers like they'e teases of her but
she's the real highlight of the entire
film to me actually she's a character
who was the standout mater's in the film
never like a few minutes he's like
spread out he is like a few minutes of
screen time spread out throughout the
film and I'm glad they did that way good
he is a character I find rather annoying
yeah I mean that's the character that
were
even small dose yeah you know and I from
what I've heard the second movie did not
listen to that no no idea there's at
least one joke that really made me crack
up yeah in the kind of delivery that
only Larry's a cable that I could do
yeah there was one that got us laughing
for you know like a minute afterwards
like sitting there cracking at it so
yeah I mean I want the supporting cast I
mean I was one of the charms for me
about the first Cars movie and this one
is definitely more focused on lightning
in Korea but I even like the supporting
characters you know because there's all
that back to route stuff and he goes he
meets uh Hudson's trainer and those
characters were cool they bring in sort
of a cats of the old great you know
there's something about these movies
where I just don't have a hard time
really caring about these characters
yeah that's something I thought this
movie is effectively well about halfway
through the movie sir really actually
giving a [ __ ] about who I was watching
on screen yeah sorry Kerry sry Lightning
McQueen win the race today huh I started
feeling that way for him and I start
feeling concerned for him I wanted I
wanted Lightning McQueen to have his
redemption and have the chance to shine
one more time
well yeah and and there are some just
nuances in the way the story moves
forward and you know the way he enters
the climax just the mood they put that
character and I thought was kind of kind
of nice like it was a more human you
know way to approach that and that's the
strength of car three for me and I don't
think it's necessarily terrific it
doesn't necessarily uh fill the shoes of
some of Pixar's best however it did
manage to put in some nifty surprises
yeah I like it I like the line I don't
like you more than the first cars I will
honestly say that you know I'm not a big
cars from one fan but there was
something about this experience and I
might I probably should not say that
because I only saw that movie one time
in the theaters I've seen it a couple
times and I mean the thing about cars to
me has always been like the movie itself
appeal is a straightforward movie pretty
much and the stuff that made it
memorable or enjoyable for me was you
know the ensemble voice cast and I
really liked the story between Paul
Newman and and Owen Wilson
yeah Hudson and McQueen and that is one
thing this movie does really well to is
they highlight a lot of key points a
duck Hall with Doc Hudson yeah
they keep they highlight
Doc Hudson throughout this film is
spirit is very much ingrained in this
whole story and it serves it as an
essential tool for lightning McQueen
throughout this whole movie as well yes
especially towards the finale and I
thought that was very effective and I
like that because we all know how Paul
Newman passed away so it's not like they
could get him to return to play Doc
Hudson again yeah but they honored him
because they have Doc Hudson's character
passed away as well so I thought like in
an interesting way it was also a nice
homage to who Paul Newman is yes and I
really appreciated that I thought this
film was structured pretty well and I
thought some finer nuances and expect
it's not exactly hilarious but it's got
a few funny moments and there's a few
good laughs out loud moment it's really
just the first half-hour that feels a
little off to me and I'm not that
invested they go first like 10 15
minutes is like a lot of setting up hey
I mean the first 10 or 15 is just that
trailer but in expanded mode yeah here's
a few races leading up to the big wreck
and now the movie because first like 15
minutes until it goes to 4 months later
is just a long montage we should
approach this a lot of different things
going on yeah and you know there's some
some extra details of the world that are
fun for them to build you know there's
Nathan Fillion has a character that
comes in with all this like lightning
McQueen merge you see like the future
what of how the cars you know work out
and train and stuff like there's some
cool wrapping paper time will tell for
me with all these but I feel like this
could be the cars movie that I at least
appreciate the most you know because I
feel like I I wasn't expecting anything
that interesting when I went in you know
and kind of got something a little
interest yeah yeah like I I liked it I
don't like don't run to see it abuse not
for you but you know I like it I don't
think I don't think I'm gonna like care
to wash it again
yeah but I'm glad I saw the ones I feel
good towards it alright well yeah I mean
if I were to give this movie a rating
I'd say it's better than one and
probably better than two uh in some ways
it's better than one and I think I would
be very surprised if it's not entirely
better than
all right well you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell that John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
house and the real rejects and go check
out our patreon for a bunch of patreon
exclusives on their perks and video
content so we did a Google hangout this
past week there was a lot of fun we'll
be doing another one very very happy and
come hug out